[Music]
it's this week we got sexy cyber warning
hot dog showdown and bizarre rental take
it away Tiffany tell them what they won
hotdogs shut down hot dog shut down I'll
make it a show that story a
cybersecurity expert has warned people
that have these high-tech sex dolls that
hackers could possibly hack into them
and kill them
what's a high-tech sex doll what are
these things capable of yeah so there's
these sex robots now that they actually
go online yeah Wi-Fi dude give sex dolls
Wi-Fi to begin with and what purpose
does that get like you want to go
download personalities share your voices
the progress of your sex doll activity
no imagine you're laying your beautiful
wife down ok and you can read the
internet the same time you're like
browsing Wikipedia about ancient
civilizations while you're having sex
it's incredible that's dope and you're
having the best kind of sex you don't
have to do anything
thank you yeah you're welcome just like
playing video games and having sex at
the same time exactly no but yeah you
haven't you guys haven't heard of these
like realistic robots I mean we've
talked about in the dnews where they're
all these you're like download
personalities your shoes actually move
their face and they can speak they're
probably cold the girls are really cold
anyway so always cool you're so cool
yeah Dan how are the thing you're so icy
yeah but this expert here they're saying
that hackers can just hack into the
robot and have full control of the
connections like the arms or legs and
they could even like have them grab
things I don't know exactly all I
picture just going out of control break
a dick
getting a knife in like killing the
actual like the robot these robots
aren't that or they'll hide or they can
actually walk over to the kitchen
grabbed a kitchen knife yeah sure dad
like what like cameras for eyes or
something and like the hackers can like
remotely control it well they can send
commands to it if they hack into I think
what it is is they'll hack in the [ __ ]
you better they never been fun before
and then while you're asleep they can
kill you you don't say they could choke
you I'm not a bad way to go but they
gotta [ __ ] you real good first to get
you my sleep yeah that's a peaceful
death Robo a towel pocket [ __ ] I
connect to the internet they have pocket
vibrators and [ __ ] that you can
connect and you have like online sex oh
yeah no we talked about talked about
that where you could put like a sleeve
on your dig and then it simulates a
[ __ ] from a certain person that you
can download yeah like the iTunes and
[ __ ] oh that's [ __ ] insane cyber
sex thank you really so that you think
those people are like oh my god what if
somebody tries to assess how important
do you think you are you narcissistic
bastard or even I guess it's not the
fact that they're important but it's
like that's how twisted people are like
there could be you'll be ok cuz I'm
pretty sure the layman isn't gonna know
how to hack a [ __ ] robot you know
what I mean or like you know that people
when they you know when they're doing
the the [ __ ] fingerprint thing they
were like oh my god what's gonna happen
when they have my fingerprint you're a
broke nobody cares about you alright
you're not that [ __ ] important that's
like recently with the whole Equifax
thing yeah yeah a lot of people are just
like paranoid about everything being fun
I might activate it I know
I got money but yeah I'll make it again
it's like one of my parents story I
remember like there's like this uh this
liquor market that we see always go to
and I remember out standing in line I
guess not like standing too close to
lady and she was like yo chill I'm
putting in my you know my whatever my
[ __ ] debit number and I was like how
much money do you have you live in the
same neighborhood you're broke I want
you to steal my fifty three dollars oh
[ __ ] that's like when your line of the
ATM to is the same [ __ ] people was like
yeah dude you're gonna be fine man
whatever you got I'm not gonna touch it
you're okay I guess that's how common it
is that people are just steal pin
numbers not gonna hands in the ghetto
then just try to have somewhere a little
bit nicer I don't even know what I would
do with your PIN number you can tell me
your PIN number right now I go to Google
and be like how do I steal someone's
bank stuff anything anymore oh [ __ ] I
think I forgot my pin number I've even
gone to the ATM in ages yeah it's been a
minute
- the problem is that we're all like
like you said we're up all night like on
Wikipedia reading about Mayan
civilizations issues so we replace all
the important shoes stupid [ __ ] does
nothing for us but we'll be killer on
Jeopardy that's actually just last night
anyhow floured trying to make myself go
to sleep I was reading out oh is it a
mystery backpack history and then
morphed in funny in the night it was I
was reading about L'Oreal if tomorrow
you had to build a woodshed in your
backyard good you with your hands but
thank God you know about backpack and
I'll talk about perfume I shampoo all
day exactly dude that's why I don't
sleep most of the time too is just I'm
always like looking up stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's nothing to [ __ ] do with
me nothing like primitive technology
right that I love that chat whole
channel ruled my whole life I look at
everything like if tinder now I'm like
tinder now I'm like if I crush this it
would be good tinder like this if I take
this and I dip it in Vaseline I could
put it into a bottle and then light it
for later
I know I know that
as half of the [ __ ] that we we argue
about to like in our interpersonal eyes
has nothing to do with any of this [ __ ]
it's so [ __ ] it's like it has no effect
on us right now and immediately but it's
like it's like sometimes in the comments
section when I'm watching these
documentaries and stuff people getting
into heated arguments about Mayan
civilizations it's like dude you weren't
even [ __ ] alive your grandparents
weren't alive during that time what the
[ __ ] yeah but they're just kidding no
Christopher Columbus came during this
time no no this time like this era
everyone's obsessive being bright and
like proving others wrong like Casey and
so everyone everyone just wants to like
go online and have their own little
research and then prove everyone wrong
or dude 9/11 is an inside job look let's
just say that it is let's say that 9/11
is a total inside job and I'm totally
open to whatever I'm fine
but the idea that you have to sit there
and [ __ ] argue about it on the
Internet it's like it happened it's like
it was an inside job you should shut the
[ __ ] up about it dude it's because
they're gonna [ __ ] find you like
every year around this time too because
it surrounding the 9/11 time everyone's
always like it was it a missile that hit
the Pentagon or was it like that wasn't
even a real plane that hit the tower or
whatever it was a [ __ ] drone or
something I've seen some of them they
they're very convincing cuz their voice
and the music yeah it's so serious no
it's true you miss me you could tell me
that I was a 9/11 hijacker if you play
that yeah like play the music right now
it's like Steve green who's an idol he
where was your 9/11 you can you prove it
it's like [ __ ] I can't prove anything
anything that is cut in the documentary
format
I mean ancient aliens is real oh yeah
anything on History Channel is like it's
fact because it's on the History Channel
I love that [ __ ] where it's like it's
like we don't we don't have those tools
to build pyramids right now and I'm like
[ __ ] are you talking about
he's like he's like you couldn't put a
piece of paper through these two slabs
that were pushed together this must have
been some sort of ancient tool or
weaponry and I'm like it's called slaves
dude they had so many [ __ ] slave of
died they were [ __ ] dinking things
with hammers for so long of course they
made a straight angle or whatever your
hell it is they cared about their
feelings it took thousands of years and
if you died they dumped you in the [ __ ]
off the line like what do we talk I just
love that [ __ ] though so Brian next
story there was this video that went
viral of a campus cop at UC Berkeley
citing a hot dog vendor I saw that dude
those hot dogs was so good and so the
video was showing this cop pretty much
robbing the dude cuz he was taking his
money he took all his money out of the
wallet so I'm gonna show you guys a
video yes why would they try the money I
don't see them taking money how did you
do with this money
here we go and look at how delicious the
hot dogs are hey guys really taller that
guy's really short it's not right how
does he know that you could drink on
campus on football games and no tickets
but a hard-working man selling hotdogs
earning a living get their money taken
away no it's not like I see people
drinking in public on campus who are not
worried fall I'm telling you right now
slow down
walk 200 feet to your left and you'll
see drinking in public but a
hard-working man gets his money taken
away and a ticket that's not right Betty
right man Danny right I mean how does he
know that that's not his personal money
yeah
see the trend I've never seen that
before he thinks every hot dog he sells
he puts the [ __ ] sale money into as
well yeah for you not for me brother not
for me and I'm disappointed as an
alumnus appointed in this campus why you
disappoint on me because because I
signed up for somebody's working hard I
will I will not but you know what this
[ __ ] home is affecting his brain he'd
that's just crazy first of all we don't
know if he was a hard-working hot dog I
know who would call on this vendor I
mean it happen I mean I mean the law is
the law so like if you're if you're
selling without a permit
if I mean there's fruit vendors all that
stuff I think so there is a law yeah
you're you're supposed to have a permit
to have a hotdog stand all that cousin
there's also food safety and all those
things where like let's say you do eat
some fruits off the street and you know
you don't know where you got it you get
sick there's all these things lemonade
stands got to close them all down all
the kids but I mean but those kids those
kids do these you're not giving me
tetanus I know so I get that like you
should have the proper paperwork all
that but sight the guy don't take his
money cuz how do you know if that's like
money from his other job waiting tables
or whatever like how would how would you
know that all that cash came from you
know the hotdogs the kind of [ __ ] up
thing about this is that there's this
controversial law that it's known as
civil asset forfeiture and so that
that's what allows police to seize
property and cash from anyone the basics
suspect of criminal activity and so
that's what gives them the legal rights
of pretty much raw people suspect is a
wide [ __ ] that oh my god no dude I
mean there's all kinds of stories about
this stuff but like if you're on a road
trip for example and you have like say
$5,000 of cash and the cop pulls you
over they can [ __ ] take your cash
exact that's what's crazy I mean if
they're proven innocent they in order
for them to get back their property it's
a really lengthy process and they have
to spend a lot of money on lawyers and
like they often never see it so what
happens does that money stay in the
evidence room for 10 years now they buy
a bunch of [ __ ] bicycle helmets with
I mean seriously and they're like well I
went to the city [ __ ] trust or some
[ __ ] he's a bike cop too so hey
but maybe the cop is trying to teach
them a lesson maybe what we don't know
is that the hot dog vendor was dropping
hot dogs on the floor and [ __ ] putting
that [ __ ] back on they're giving it to
someone they got sick and [ __ ]
diarrhea all night but that is the
chance to take and especially if it's a
bacon-wrapped hot dog I know it probably
fall in the ground if anything if I eat
it and it wasn't dropping the foam you
pissed it's like dude it tasted way
different yeah this isn't a street dog
it needs to be on the [ __ ] Street is
that relish or is that urine right
that's why ballpark dogs are like nine
dollars because they're not on the floor
I know how [ __ ] gay people don't know
that yeah so the person who filmed this
video his name is Martin and he started
up a GoFundMe page for Kwan the vendor
here because he felt that I was just
wrong the fact that they took away his
hard-earned money and initially he had a
ten thousand dollar goal I don't know
why so much but now he's rich right hey
someone tell these [ __ ] how much of
that money do you think is gonna go to
the hot dog vendor know it so the so
Martin has been constantly posting on
the GoFundMe page saying that not a cent
is going to sue Martin all of it is
going to one all gonna go towards like
his legal like fees and like trying to
get like personal legal and professional
matters is what he's saying
hmm dude the real moneys in [ __ ] hot
dogs and things holy [ __ ] he doesn't
need to pay legal fees just take the
money and just stop working I want to
start a GoFundMe somebody robbed me now
please once and got a matey jeez that's
crazy
sign us up right I feel like this is a
setup you're gonna to split that money
with the cop right
I want the cop to show up a go fund me
and open their wallet I'd be like we're
taking all this [ __ ] money there's a
petition out right now for the cop to
get removed from the police because
they're saying that this cop has had so
many controversies around him and that
the police department keeps covering up
for him there was one story that came
out like he's just robbing people so one
of them like someone commented on the
GoFundMe saying I know this cop used to
come to my high school at the time and
sees weed and booze and cash from all
these students and he would never turn
them in wrestling tickets he wouldn't
give them citations or anything he would
just take this WWE ticket looks criminal
yeah we're taking this one yeah yeah you
[ __ ] sounds like the cop we would be
okay taking people's drugs money I don't
do that I do it on a higher level not
normal civilians yeah and this other
story that came out too which I to my
knowledge it hasn't been verified but
apparently the same cop is a homosexual
and apparently like that has more to do
with no I'm gonna add to it so he's
almost sexual and he sexually assaulted
another homosexual man and so this man
is coming out saying that the police
department has been covering up for this
cop so there's some of that big ass dude
the gay cop yeah god damn he's very
forceful he wanted to shove a dick down
your throat is gonna happen that one
victim is saying that there there was
another police officer filming the whole
incident he's claiming is that he filmed
it and that in a mini DVD and that this
mini DVD was copied and passed around
the department like for some sort of
like porn so he raped somebody I don't
know exactly what he groped his dick
he was like forcefully petting him down
to the point where he kept telling him
like stop touching me because he kept
touching his genital area and that the
cop was like I can touch whoever I want
wherever I want is what the victim is
saying but I don't know if this is all
true do this story doesn't sound real
man yeah why would even use DVDs
many dvds do like blu-ray already at
that time I mean we had to video saying
we have we read yeah we were never late
with GOG wall and we're born yeah so
there's this controversy with this cop
and so a lot of people just want him off
the force
and they're just upset that they keep
covering up for him but yeah the whole
reason why this video went viral is
because of the fact that he confiscated
the money not knowing whether or not he
liked that money in his wallet with his
own money not even from the sales of hot
rod you something it's like a villain
from like Dexter like everybody's worst
nightmare he's like the [ __ ] is
six-foot-five rapist copy homosexual
rape is calm he walks around as a crab
in balls you terrible sober last story
there's this London flat that is going
for eight thousand pounds a week that
you can rent and it's a very interesting
home with very interesting decor I'm
gonna show you oh a see it and sexual
whoa what the [ __ ] it's a museum
chairman mao's [ __ ] it's a communist
house yeah cradling a child this person
is a comedian spray some crap on the
wall this is it that's kind of cool
that's pretty dope right there
I can kiss it with each that says us
right there it's some kind of slang
right I could read it but I cannot miss
North Korean dialect yeah yeah some kind
of slang I mean I'm used to the idea of
the original one yeah it's kind of cool
yes
polgár wax or wax that you're do that's
[ __ ] creepy underneath the staircase
john paul ii hope john paul ii yeah why
is he there with all the dictators
think about it for a second why
the Vatican oh yeah the Vatican all the
sex scandals [ __ ] yeah dude you see the
Pope got a black eye that fool like fell
into the popemobile yeah oh really yes I
don't mean that fool I mean you're
laughing at his black guy I'm just
saying laughter that we can't laugh at
that it was so funny there are no King I
was cracking up because in the interview
he's talking about how much he liked by
hates Trump but then all I see in the
black eye yeah respect yeah I respect
the guy but it's like damn brother can
we address this please [ __ ] have your
face is swollen
no yeah there's a pillow with Putin
Putin pillow I like this place and they
need a little bit of Joe Mallya in there
yeah it was like it yeah oh [ __ ] that's
kind of cool a talk it's made from the
wing of a World War 2 plane oh let's go
oh I like furniture like that it was
place expensive is [ __ ] really big
how many room is this place I really
like how they captured this I'm a
communist date but I'm trying to be
ballin look me because if you ever
watched those documentaries about North
Korea or whatever and then when they try
to go extravagant they're still outdated
so all their furniture is like 1970s but
like really clean and brand-new so it's
really weird that part of the house
looks totally very modern yeah that
doesn't fit with everything else that's
there it's like a Hawaiian luxury yeah
they have two terraces cuz in London is
that looks like jenna is huge
and so this home it actually belongs to
a director so he's a troll Polanski now
he doesn't have that kind of money his
name is wrong roland emmerich
independence day' godzilla' and 10,000
BC that's this guy so that and in the
[ __ ] pendency yeah and $10 Breezies
like he's worse yeah
I liked it I liked him with those
big-ass tall Egyptians came out I was
like [ __ ] yeah he's the guy who does all
the like destruction porn he was like
the creator of all that yeah like watch
the White House gets bloated watch pears
gets bloated
he was like Michael Bay before Michael
Bay right oh yeah he he like he like
taught Mike he's like Michael Bay's like
first time touching himself I mean
Michael Bay's like what is this oh [ __ ]
I'm finding things about my body I
didn't know before
thank you rollin on his pad for 8,000
pounds a week
so is he down and out does he need money
I'm not sure I don't know why he has it
up for rent but a product is the
Independence Day - dude [ __ ] yeah
he probably needs a lot of bread from in
a long time oh yeah good no because that
dad was terrible
and it did not it did not do well
Independence Day - was so bad I
downloaded it and I deleted it got it
for free and I watched it half way and
then I deleted it and I wanted it out of
my computer I hope you guys enjoyed this
video for more please subscribe to our
Channel and you can check out the last
video right here
[Music]